the White House says it will not
participate in an impeachment hearing
that's scheduled for this week in a
letter to the House Judiciary Committee
last night the White House's top lawyer
slammed the impeachment investigation is
baseless and highly partisan Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with more on
this story good morning to you Nancy so
what's new about this week's hearing
well this week the House Judiciary
Committee Gale takes the reins of the
inquiry that's the committee that's
responsible for drafting articles of
impeachment and for the first time the
White House is actually going to have
the opportunity to do some of the
questioning at Wednesday's hearing but
last night the White House rejected that
offer in a letter last night to the
House Judiciary Committee the chief
White House Counsel said we do not
intend to participate in your Wednesday
hearing because it exacerbates the
complete lack of due process and
fundamental fairness for the president
this is a complete American waste of
time right here congressional
Republicans this weekend criticized the
Democrats accelerated timeline they want
to get at this president right now
before the before everybody completely
sees through the process Sham of the
elections for next year lawmakers on the
House Intelligence Committee will get
just one day to review a report drafted
over the Thanksgiving break the report
summarizes weeks of hearings and
depositions and will be sent to the
Judiciary Committee tomorrow just in
time for Wednesday's hearing we are
gonna proceed expeditiously members of
the Judiciary Committee will take those
findings plus hear testimony from
constitutional scholars before they draw
up articles of impeachment Democrats
will lay out their case that the
president abused his office by
withholding military aid to pressure
Ukraine to investigate his campaign
rival Joe Biden Democrats argue the best
way for White House lawyers to defend
the president is to show up if he has
not done anything wrong we were
certainly anxious to hear his
explanation of that the White House has
not ruled out participating in future
hearings but it must make a decision by
Friday and propose possible witnesses I
think would be to the president's
advantage
his attorneys there that is his right
but I can also understand how he is
upset at the illegitimate process today
the House Judiciary Committee is
expected to announce the law professors
and constitutional scholars that will
testify at Wednesday's hearing the
President himself will not be in town he
actually heads to London later this
morning for a two-day NATO summit Tony
all right Nancy thank you very much Stan